repeatedly we are told that thousands of
years ago the average person was much
fitter than we are
the reason we're all so out of shape
today is that we spend so much time
sitting so much time looking at screens
so much time stressed
it's because we eat all the wrong things
and never get any sunlight we are
increasingly spending all of our time
indoors alone hardly moving I mean it
doesn't sound great when you put it like
that
with all that in mind we might be
tempted to say that it's society's fault
that we're out of shape or at least that
Modern Life doesn't exactly help to keep
us fitting healthy
that's what I want to examine in this
video is this true how responsible are
we for our own Fitness what could we do
to build a fitter Humanity
just to be clear I certainly don't
believe that there's some big conspiracy
at play here there are accusations
floating around the internet that our
governments want to keep us weak and
docile
even if the government were adding
synthetic hormones to the water supply
which they are not the resulting drop in
testosterone would be tiny and have
absolutely zero effect on your voting
behaviors some people have gotten very
rich talking freely online about how
little Free Speech they have yes vs
their narrative is a marketing ploy to
sell overpriced predatory Drop Shipping
courses and make already very rich sales
people richer a matrix within the Matrix
if you will
so I guess what I'm trying to say here
is that there is no Matrix there's no
conspiracy here there's just a
collection of cultural habits and then
there's the hedonistic treadmill I
should also make clear at this point
that I am not talking about health as
much as Fitness
modern nutrition certainly has its
problems there are definitely issues
with Healthcare we breathe in a lot of
pollution
but that is beyond the scope of this
video today we're looking at Fitness
so what is a very real problem is our
sitting our long stretches of stressed
indoor sitting punctuated by short walks
to the train bus or car followed by more
sitting this contributes to weight gain
yes but more concerning and even more
pernicious I believe is the loss of
Mobility
I've personally suffered back pain from
sitting it's one of the reasons I went
all in on functional training I saw the
damage that this lifestyle was doing to
me I was someone who wanted to perform
like a superhero and yet I couldn't
squat at the time due to knee pain and
poor ankle Mobility I was constantly
putting my lower back out
my friends considered me extremely fit
this is nuts the lack of cardio that
comes from sitting for long stretches is
also a problem leading to a weaker heart
and higher risk of all cause mortality
most of us are also stressed out for
this entire period at work and our
breathing is likely shallow too owing to
our poor posture and let's be clear one
hour at the gym a few times a week is
not enough to make up for sitting the
entire rest of the time
and most gym routines do very little to
address these most pressing issues
anyway most people will either train to
lose weight with large amounts of cardio
which at least has the added benefit of
improving aerobic fitness or they'll
train their mirror muscles the pecs abs
and shoulders with the aim of improving
Aesthetics
those by the way are the muscles that
are already tightest and shortest from
all the sitting
skipping leg day might be a meme but
it's also very much the norm we're
piling dysfunction on top of dysfunction
I could point to our Insidious obsession
with Aesthetics as very much encouraging
this Instagram figures pumped with
steroids or cosmetic enhancements
projecting images of Immaculate Health
that we can't possibly measure up to and
are not blaming Instagram or Tick Tock
here before that there are magazine
covers I was self-employed so I had the
best case scenario but still the sheer
volume of writing I had to complete
meant that anything other than sitting
for large parts of my day was out of the
question
many people literally aren't allowed to
get up other than for toilet breaks and
now I'm aware of how much damage this is
doing I can literally feel myself
seizing up as I sit for an extended
period
it feels itchy and this is so much worse
for certain cross-sections of society
too
when my wife and I first moved to London
we lived in a flat so small there was
literally nowhere to do push-ups this is
still the reality for many people but
now imagine if those are your living
conditions and you also have kids maybe
you're a single parent maybe you work
long hours and have to pay for a nanny
you don't have access to a gym you're
exhausted most of the time and the only
food you have the time and money to
provide your kids with is microwaved
lasagna you feel like a terrible parent
because your kids deserve more but what
are you going to do when you get home at
6 pm and when a pack of mints is
stretching the budget
and now you're expected to get to the
gym as well or at least do some kind of
home workout
who's going to fill out those School
forms wash up prep the kids for tomorrow
chances are you're gonna be woken up
during the night anyways it's so easy to
point the finger at someone who is out
of shape to tell them that they only
have themselves to blame for their poor
health that it's their responsibility
everyone should have a six-pack for
claim some influences everyone should
drive a sports car your health should
always be your number one priority it's
such a naive and unhelpful stance when
you're struggling to make ends meet when
there isn't enough time in the day your
health isn't the number one priority
Junior might like it to be but looking
after your family is putting food on the
table dressing your kids paying rent and
getting by day to day
so much of modern Fitness assumes a
certain level of privilege usually youth
as well and free time and that's simply
not the reality for the vast majority of
people
YouTube creators do not provide a
reflective sample of the population
so that's all a bit depressing maybe but
there are as ever Rays of Hope Modern
Life isn't all bad for all we aren't in
great shape we are living longer there
are now cures for more diseases and we
have access to so much information those
who wish to can educate themselves on
matters pertaining to their Fitness in
ways that we never could have before the
internet might be shorting our attention
spans but it's teaching us to quickly
absorb huge amounts of information and
is giving us tools to create amazing
things
while social media is demoralizing for
some it's motivating for others and what
some people are capable of in terms of
top tier performance is absolutely
incredible
driving even is an incredible form of
brain training teaching us to be more
focused and alert
so there are arrays of Hope but what we
need now is for society to move more in
the right direction and I'd argue to
stop chasing Financial growth and to
start putting the health and happiness
of the population first
what might that look like
firstly we need to prioritize healthy
varied movement this starts at work many
of us are trapped in our offices for the
majority of the day and so our employers
have a duty of care right now they're
neglecting that Duty breaks from the
desk should therefore be mandated that
might look like a 20-minute break every
two hours and a longer lunch break maybe
a two hour break you can't force people
to exercise during this time but they
would have that option and if workplaces
could provide those facilities even
better
this is even more crucial at schools
schools should seek to maintain and
encourage the energy mobility and love
of play that's inherent in children not
stamp it out we should also likewise
strongly consider four-day working weeks
would this negatively impact the bottom
line of some of those businesses I mean
maybe but
you give people more time and freedom
and they'll be able to fill that time
with more nourishing Pursuits and there
should be options here governing bodies
should support and encourage the
formation of physical clubs and
activities free child care and a
universal living wage would further help
to take this pressure off now I'm not an
economist so I can't tell you how
feasible that is but I suspect it might
be a little bit more feasible than many
of us presume funny how work or die
doesn't result in the best physical or
mental health
it's funny because a lot of people are
so keen on having the freedom to you
know someday buy a yacht that they're
willing to live most of their lives
paycheck to paycheck forgetting that the
people who buy the yacht are like the
0.1 percent
[Music]
as a culture we need to start
celebrating and normalizing movement we
need to encourage more play we need to
lighten up
this starts with what we wear even most
of us wear trousers or pants to
Americans they're so tight we couldn't
squat even if we were able to our shoes
are literally crippling squishing our
toes together shortening our calves
deadening our sense of connection to the
ground which is why I wear barefoot
shoes and that brings me to today's
sponsor Vivo Barefoot they make in my
opinion some of the very best barefoot
shoes around it is a shoes with a wide
toe box with a very thin sole so you can
feel the ground underneath you and no
heel toe drop so that you're not being
forced into this unnatural position not
only are they better for you on the
day-to-day but they give you that
freedom to run and jump and climb while
still looking smart enough to wear into
a workplace you can get 15 off a pair by
following the link in the description
and using the code pioneer 15.
session today I've come to London I'm
getting my feet 3D scanned for a really
cool project they've got called Vivo
biome so basically this is going to scan
my feet tell me a little bit about them
and then I should get shoes delivered to
me that will be perfectly tailor-made
for me so they're going to be like
fitting like a glove and hopefully
that'll make a big difference to how
they feel and how I move in them and
yeah miles away from stuffing yourself
into rigid and comfortable stuffy shoes
with a big heel and a narrow toe box
I'll let you know how I get on with
these once I've got the shoes but you
guys can get involved in this as well if
you follow the link in the description
down below
you do lunges in a coffee shop and
everyone looks at you like you've gone
insane guys I'm just moving remember
moving nobody likes it when I run to the
shops and I'm not trying to be all
Superior here like oh I'm the guy who
moves around and these people are just
stuck in their boring work lives that's
normal I recognize that I'm weird and
not everyone has to run but I feel like
we need to normalize this ever since
I've been moving more regularly
throughout the day training in smaller
batches throughout the day I've had so
much more energy and I felt so much less
stiff I'm apparent who barely gets any
sleep who's quite overworked and I
genuinely have more energy and vibrancy
than I did five years ago
in an ideal future I'd love to see
architecture City Planning and interior
design take this into account instead of
trying to funnel as many people into
shops as possible and facilitate
Commerce City should be designed to
naturally encourage movement I'm talking
more calisthenics Parks playgrounds
green spaces and more people tell you
off when you balance along their Garden
Wall to what they were balance beams
along the side of the road what if all
benches also had dip bars or pull-up
bars what if all stairs also had the
option to Traverse the wall next to them
instead again you can't and shouldn't
force people to train and we need to be
mindful of emergencies disabilities and
others and of course these things would
need to be safe so these movement
options should always be just that
options but if they are fun and
interesting they should be inherently
motivating encouraging play and
experimentation for its own sake
interior designers should stop viewing
empty spaces as dead spaces as wasted
opportunities rather empty spaces to
move around and crawl and play should
take a center stage this would just
inherently make us so much fitter
movement shouldn't be something we do
occasionally in the gym regular varied
movement should be the norm the default
it gets the blood flowing keeps the
metabolism active spikes protein
synthesis reinforces neural Pathways
boosts energy
and if all this sounds a bit crazy
remember that this is what our planet
looks like naturally this is the default
before there were cities and streets
that funneled us down crowded narrow
paths there were trees to climb rocks to
jump on Sand to tumbling rivers to swim
in big open Meadows to run in I've
talked at length about the ways in which
natural landscapes Forge stronger and
more resilient bodies how doing a
pull-up from a tree branch with its
varied Heights angles vectors and more
will always be superior to practicing
the same linear movement on a bar over
and over so perhaps even better than a
pull-up bar by a bench is just a tree by
a bench that has like an invitation to
climb it it's not like nature doesn't
exist anymore this is still the case
across huge swaths of land but it's
segregated and cut off
here in the UK a huge majority of
Greenland is privately owned with
restricted access private landowners and
organizations that have inherited these
massive plots of land now jealously
guard them and prevent Public Access
governments won't do anything to
challenge this because they need the
funding from those wealthy players and
because they are those wealthy players
according to the book who owns England
over half the country is owned by less
than one percent of the population what
possible justification is there for a
single individual or family owning acres
of land that they can't possibly make
use of
the right to rain movement exists to
challenge these ideas personally I
believe this to be a very worthy cause
remember this isn't just about having a
nice place to picnic it's about being
cut off from the natural environment
that promotes Optimal Health and Fitness
education is also key as we encourage
more movement and tries to support the
basic needs of the population we should
also be explaining the importance of
regular movement
kids learn a bit about anatomy and PE
but I wish I'd learned the importance of
the hip hinge or how to retract my
scapula we need to stop idolizing
aesthetic physiques and focus instead on
performant ones and imagine if we had
regular Fitness checkups just as some
countries encourage regular Health
checkups to try and screen for early
signs of disease the same approach could
be taken to Fitness this might include
cardio tests Mobility challenges and
checks to look for compensatory movement
patterns and other signs of dysfunction
but the obvious irony is that a fitter
and healthier population would also be
more productive but that's not the point
I mean why are we so obsessed with
growth and productivity in the first
place
these changes may be decades away they
may never come so what can we do in the
meantime
well we can't change our environments
what we can do is to change our
relationship to the environment
stares offer an opportunity to jump a
walk to the shops can just as easily be
a run to the shops we can educate
ourselves about movement and we can
share our successes with others we can
lift each other up that's one of the
things I try and do on this channel and
as we do we should stop comparing
ourselves to each other we should quit
the rat race and then when I say quit
the rat race I don't mean start a Drop
Shipping business that's just going more
into the rat race I mean detaching
ourselves from the outcomes changing our
goals I recently had the option to grow
this channel to take on staff and maybe
get a bigger office
I have invitations to do interviews on
big podcasts in other parts of the world
for which I'm very grateful and honored
this would undoubtedly raise my profile
and bring in more cash but I spent some
time reflected and thought and you know
what I don't want to get bigger sure I'd
like to reach a million subscribers that
would be a Personal Achievement but I'm
earning enough money to support my
family and I love what I'm doing every
time I have an interview it stresses me
the heck out every new opportunity just
means I'm rushing more and spending less
time with my family actually means I'm
training less which is kind of the point
I have less time to exercise when I have
more work to do so why not just sit back
and enjoy it enjoy this extremely
privileged position I'm in to get paid
to make content about Fitness and
superheroes to work in an office that
has a pull-up bar in it if I wasn't in
this extremely fortunate position I
would be working hard to earn enough to
comfortably look after my family but
then I'd stop why would a manager on a
high salary ever want a promotion I've
never understood the CEOs that stay on
long after they've earned enough money
to retire to a Paradise Island long
after the job role is completely warped
from the thing they were presumably
passionate about to begin with
when they start acquiring businesses in
different Industries and crushing the
individuality out of them and the same
mentality can be applied to other
aspects of life too when we stop
competing with the world and focus on
happiness we become infinitely Freer
if you're struggling to get by you
probably won't have the free time or the
resources to maintain your optimal
Fitness but once you do maybe it's time
to stop pushing for more on to focus on
actually doing that we're taught that
this Obsession would work with progress
with business is the grown-up thing to
do it's Noble and stuff
[Music]
keep your billion dollar paycheck if it
means sitting in meetings all day
[Music]
so I hope you found this video
interesting guys it potentially got a
little bit political at points but I
tried not to get too controversial I
might have gotten a bit carried away
though because I was listening to cool
violin music whilst I was writing the
dangers of cool violin music
I guess what I wanted to say here is
that Fitness doesn't entirely come down
to individual responsibility we should
be sympathetic to those who find it
difficult to find the time or resources
to train
to ignore the impact of socio-economic
pressures is naive
to help solidify these ideas I'm
suggesting the term motion Punk or
movement Punk like solar Punk or
cyberpunk before it motion Punk can be a
genre an aesthetic a philosophy or a
subculture it envisions a world where
natural human movement is the priority
and where architecture politics cultural
norms and fashion all exist in service
of that in this world cities are
designed with built-in movement options
that would be inherently fun and
engaging like giant playgrounds or
levels of a computer game I used a
mid-journey to visualize what this might
look like
this to stimulate the body and mind
through regular commutes nature would be
an integral part of this design and
would blend seamlessly into the design
alongside vertical scaffolding slides
swings and climbing walls other travel
options include human-powered machines
we have bikes but how about power risers
what else could we envision
technology in general would aim to
augment and not replace our natural
features think maximumism not
transhumanism where technology trains Us
in exciting new ways rather than
replacing body parts or changing us
entirely
people wear clothing that values
function over form loose fitting
trousers and minimal shoes activities
like dance martial arts parkour
gymnastics and climbing are celebrated
it's normal to see people running and
jumping in the streets governments exist
to support freedom of movement to take
care of our fundamental needs so that
we'd be free to express ourselves and to
explore there is a spirit of fun and of
playful Rebellion against the boring
static and self-serious
it's just an idea but it's a vision of a
world where Society supports rather than
challenges Fitness
maybe it can stimulate some discussion
[Music]
this is my blueprint for a fitter
Humanity what's yours let me know down
below it should be an interesting
comment section
thanks again for watching guys and bye
for now